hello
and welcome to the learnstorm growth
mindset live stream i'm rachel a senior
communications manager at khan academy
and i am so excited to welcome you to
the khan academy offices here in sunny
california
today's live stream is going to be about
60 minutes and we're going to split it
up into two parts
up first we're going to cover the live
stream learnstorm program what it's all
about and what it can do for your
classroom
next we'll turn our attention to our
fabulous panel to answer your questions
about growth mindset but first a few
tips
if you have any questions about growing
growth mindset or learnstorm please type
your questions and comments and our
helpful moderators will answer your
questions for those who are trying to
view by youtube i'm really sorry we're
having some technical problems so we're
just on facebook for the moment
but our questions might be asked to our
panel later on
i also very much recommend that you
maximize your screen we'll be going
through a few of the growth mindset
activities and you'll definitely want to
see them in full effect and lastly if
you can't stay for the full live stream
we'll miss you but don't worry we'll
record it and we'll send out the
recording later on this week
i have three amazing guests with me
today that i'll introduce in just a few
moments but first let me share with you
a little about learnstorm
learnstorm is khan academy's free back
to school program that gives teachers a
powerful way to jump start the school
year
by combining mindset activities and
skills practice across subjects
learnstorms motivates classrooms and
builds students confidence and yes you
can still sign up for lornstorm through
october so hop to it if you haven't
already there's also some time to win
some awesome prizes
this year all across the u.s teachers
and their students can sign up for a
learnstorm learnstorm and khan academy
are free and always will be learnstream
was possible thanks to the awesome
support of mathworks so thank you
mathworks
learnstorm can be implemented flexibly
by teachers as in in class practice for
homework or for both but in order to to
get the most out of learnstorm please
follow these steps
one
sign up and assign
two
master skills
three
build mindsets and four celebrate
progress
of course
in order to even participate you must
sign up for khan academy by going to
khan academy.org and enroll in
learnstorm from your coach dashboard
once you have your account all set up
with your class and students teachers
can assign all the content available on
khan academy including grammar history
biology not just math in addition to
core k-12 subjects learnstorm um
learnstorm includes access to con ap
lessons created by former ap teachers
and ap exam reviewers covering subjects
like ap physics ap calculus ap
government and politics and more and
then don't forget to enroll your class
and learn storm
next it's time for you
your students to master skills
regardless of the way your teachers
decide to implement learnstorm teachers
can track student participation get
real-time insights and when and when
someone is struggling
this enables teachers to spend more time
differentiating differentiating
instruction and providing targeted help
with learners of all levels
this picture
is of miss cotto of watsonville
california she participated in
learnstorm last year and you can hear
all about her experience on our website
at learnstorm.comacademy.org
thirdly the topic of the our
growth mindset
this year based on feedback from
teachers who use activities last year we
have not one but two curriculums based
on age group
in the elementary middle school
curriculum students have seven
activities to learn alongside this brain
character thinky pinky and his friends
we'll scroll through one of these
awesome activities now
which were created in partnership with
pertz a standard research center
each activity has articles videos and
these are essential reflection points
where students can really take a moment
to internalize and apply these concepts
to their lives
in the high school curriculum students
have new lessons on belonging and will
learn through testimonials and case
studies we also have focus on
highlighting people from many different
backgrounds and diverse experiences so
students can learn from a full spectrum
of experiences
we've also made a comprehensive teacher
guide and lesson plans that include bell
ringers class discussions sample
communications to parents you can assign
all of these growth mindset activities
by clicking assign in the upper right
hand corner and students complete
activities they develop learning
strategies and build confidence to
overcome challenges in the classroom and
beyond
the growth mindset activities are a
chance for you to make a lasting change
in students lives and as they continue
into adulthood just so very important
lastly the cherry on the sunday
celebrating
the biggest part of learnstorm which has
led to many classroom celebrations is
the learnstorm tracker here's how it
works access the learnstorm tracker from
the learnstorm banner on your teacher
coach dashboard once you click on the
blue button you should be taken to your
class learn storm tracker we've included
a demo for you to see what it's all
about
as your students complete assignments on
the con cad academy with your assigned
to them their uh their rings on their
learners from traffic will populate and
fill up
once your students have completed a set
of number of assignments based on the
number of students in your class their
ring will fill up and celebrations will
occur this year there are a near
infinite number of rings which means
there are so many moments for
celebration encouragement or perhaps
friendly competition between a
neighboring class
each ring is three times the number of
students in your class
students get super excited regardless of
the age and we've even seen students
jump out of their seats in celebration
for a limited time learn storm um learn
to sort of learn storm we have growth
mindex growth mindset activities that
you can also assign to your class to
receive credit in your learnstorm
tracker
all right
enough from me
i am very excited to introduce our panel
who will tell us more about growth
mindset
all right today we have
dave ponescu founding director of pertz
a centered at stanford university that
helps educators apply insights from the
behavioral sciences to create safe and
engaging learning environments that
foster student motivation and resilience
annie brock
a former teacher and author of the
growth mindset coach a month-by-month
guide of how to implement mindset in
your classroom
and samala robinson a current 4th grade
teacher in independence missouri who has
developed many creative ways to help her
students learning mindsets so welcome to
our panel
so my first question is for dave can you
tell us more of what is growth mindset
yeah so uh growth mindset is is really
the belief that our abilities and our
intelligence are something that we can
grow by applying effort um to the right
uh
effort appropriately to the right kinds
of learning strategies and it's
distinguished usually from a fixed
mindset which is to believe that our
abilities um our and our intelligence
are fixed there's something like eye
color something that we really can't
change about ourselves
um now it's important to know that
growth mindset isn't to believe that
everyone's uh
the same or that everyone's equally
intelligent or learns the same way um
rather is to believe that no matter how
smart you are you can always become
smarter
by learning from your mistakes and
challenging yourself to learn more
very good
and
i guess this is a question for annie and
sam
um
why is growth mindset important for
students
um
i think
growth mindset is just really essential
for students because so many students
come to school with us
feeling limitations whether they put
them on themselves or they put them on
or they've been put on by someone else
and i think when students develop growth
mindsets they start to understand that
that their possibilities are limitless
that with hard work and effort they can
make great achievements in school
there's a quote in carol dweck's book
mindset
that's a person's true potential is
unknown and unknowable and it's
impossible to foresee what can be
accomplished with years of passion toil
and training and that's like my personal
teaching mantra because i want to enter
school every day and just feel like i'm
not i i'm not going to limit any kid any
kid can achieve anything if they want to
put in the work and you know when you're
a student and you go into the classroom
and you look around and there's 20 or 25
other learners it's really easy to get
in that fixed mindset space where you're
looking around and contemplating like
why is why does this um come so quickly
to her or why is he so great at this and
and it's so hard for me
um it's easy to tell yourself the story
that oh they're just blessed with that
ability or oh they they just have some
natural talent or natural affinity for
math or art or music or whatever it's
hard to reckon with the the truth that
effort is what leads to achievement but
we have to care about our students
enough not to let them get away with the
easy thing which is just to believe that
they're not cut out for it
and i just think it's so important to
bring growth mindset into our our
schools and into our classrooms because
when we
give kids um the tools the language of
growth mindset the tools to use use
growth mindset in their learning
they learn how to put in effort to to
push hard to fight to achieve goals and
and their kids who are achieving goals
will turn into adults who achieve goals
and we need adults who are
tenacious and willing to to solve
difficult problems and so that starts
that starts in our classrooms yeah
i think the great thing about growth
mindset is it gives every single child
hope
it's no longer this mindset of okay
those are the kids who are smart and i'm
never going to be one of them everyone
is on a journey everyone can learn and
annie kind of touched on this at the
beginning of the year i describe
knowledge to my kids as a sphere to help
them visualize it and there's an
infinite number of doors on the sphere
and we've all got these keys and it can
be so frustrating to look over and watch
your friend put their key in and turn
and the door opens yet when you put your
key in
it doesn't work
that's not where we stop though that's
where you get with your teacher and we
are going to figure this out we're going
to figure out how our brain works and
we're going to keep going because you
deserve that moment where you put your
key in and all your effort has paid off
and that door finally turns and the
great thing about growth mindset is
embedded within it is goal setting it's
reflection and we're truly empowering
our kids to be lifelong learners not
just fourth grade learners right
so i guess uh for annie and for dave
there's so much out there about growth
mindset what is important for teachers
to focus in on when fostering a growth
mindset for students yeah so i think a
really great place to start is by laying
that foundation by helping them really
understand um that the brain is
malleable really helping them understand
the neuroscience behind behind growth
mindset so again i think that's that's
really just the foundation so that's a
great place to start and i think the the
learn storm growth mindset activities
really do a good job of laying that
foundation um but i think it's really
important to go to go deeper than that
too and i think um what teachers can do
to do that is to create this growth
mindset culture which is characterized
by being a really a safe place uh for
students to to feel like they can make
mistakes and where they can challenge
themselves without without worrying
about how their teacher will see them or
how their how their peers will see them
um it's a place where where they'll feel
like um like their mistakes will be will
be celebrated as long as they're
learning from them and where their where
growth is is prioritized over
proficiency
i think what teachers can do is they can
really make it obvious that in their
class the thing that matters most is how
much they're learning um and that
they're there um their relationship with
their students isn't one of of judge but
rather one of coach so a lot of the time
t students worry that their teacher
they really see their teacher as a judge
someone who's there to evaluate whether
they're a good learner or bad learner
whether they're smart or dumb
but when they see their teachers as a
judge in that way they can really get in
the way of learning because it's very
hard to be vulnerable if you're really
worried about um about how the person
will see you um and to ask for help
but in contrast if a teacher really
creates this kind of growth mindset
culture and really really talks with
their students and helps them see
themselves see them as their coach
as someone who's really there to to
bring out the best of them and help them
grow the most
then that really changes the way
students feel about challenging
themselves and helps them feel much more
confident and comfortable really putting
themselves out there and challenging
themselves i love that um yeah i agree
with everything dave said and i you know
i would also number one is just teaching
kids
like what the mindsets are giving them
the understanding of how learning
actually happens in their bodies how how
their brains work what equipment we all
have the pr that process of of um
creating connections in our brain is the
same for everyone so just giving them
that knowledge is key and then secondly
giving them challenging work and that's
going to look differently for every kid
challenging there's many definitions in
a classroom of what challenging work is
but giving them challenging work and
then supporting them as they meet the
high expectations that you've set for
them
in doing that you're creating a growth
mindset culture because you know truly
if the work is easy the mindset is
irrelevant if kids are just breezing
through things so um if to foster
to me a growth mindset classroom looks
like lots of chances on your path to
mastery lots of chances to get it right
a teacher who's modeling growth mindset
so talking through the process
talking through your struggles and
valuing growth over perfection and i
love how you talked about normalizing
mistakes or looking at mistakes as an
opportunity to learn i have a funny
story i was chatting with some khan
academy ambassadors and a teacher said
that
she had taught her second grade class
about what growth mindset was and and
they're working towards like um looking
at mistakes and failure is just a part
of learning and and you know you teach
these things and you tell the kids these
things and you and you're not sure if
it's resonating until it you know they
it comes back to you in some form and
she said one kiddo who started the year
with a little bit of a fixed mice that
came in um with some homemade science
that said this is a mistake making place
but making was spelled m-a-k-e-i-n-g
and i know that's such a good story i'm
like that's such a great example of what
growth mindset looks like it is it is
trying it's putting yourself out there
it's being being vulnerable and i can't
imagine what kind of amazing classroom
that teacher has where a kid um
internalizes that and then is willing to
just show up and and put himself out
there so so i you know you can foster
growth mindset
in your classroom in a bunch of
different ways but to me it looks like
what is growth mindset giving
challenging work setting high
expectations and then being that support
structure for the kids to achieve their
goals
well thank you thank you for sharing
that story that sounds like a really
amazing way to foster learning it's sort
of the best environment that we want for
all of our our students which is so
great
um dave i know you know that we khan
academy worked with you a lot on these
uh growth mindset activities can you
give me some highlights of the
curriculum
uh yeah so i mean it was really fun
first of all working on that curriculum
with the khan academy team i always
enjoy that um so i mean i think one
thing i really appreciate about it is
that it really i think does a good job
of hitting a lot of the main themes that
are important for lay that for laying
that foundation for a growth mindset and
it does it in a really fun and engaging
way in part in no small part thanks to
thinking pinky who's a great uh great
character to have accompany you on this
ride um but yeah you know it really hits
at some of the scientific evidence
behind the growth mindset it really
helps students understand how powerful
mistakes can be how they can really be
allies in this learning journey if you
take time to really reflect on them and
really understand what that means what
opportunities you have to learn better
and to better develop
it also helps students set ambitious
goals uh because
if you're you know if you're not really
challenging yourself and it doesn't
matter if you have a growth mindset if
you're just thinking boy i sure could
grow but if you're not you know doing
things that actually challenge you to
grow you won't and so i think it helps
students set those goals um and really
understand why doing that is important
um and then i think last but not least
and also really you know when you when
you're really doing that when you're
going for those ambitious goals and
pushing yourself
you're gonna struggle and you're you're
going to get frustrated sometimes and
there's also really good advice there
for students and for teachers around how
to deal with those inevitable struggles
that come up when you're really pushing
yourself great exactly
and uh i guess sam just for for those
teachers who are watching who are like
i'm i need some practical applications
of how to do this and like what's
happening now you participated in
learnstorm for a couple years now
uh what are you looking forward to for
learnstorm and the growth mindset
activities for this year
well i really like that there's been a
bit of a shift in in the learnstorm in
that now they are aligned to elementary
middle school and high school and i
think that helps a tremendous amount you
know we spend so much time at the
beginning of the year doing these direct
lessons where we're talking about what's
actually happening in your brain
and what's happening
in your body when you become stressed
and dealing with the frustrations and
everything and we do all these different
activities and then just at the perfect
time learnstorm comes in
and the kids get to hear that
information in a different way and
interact with it in a different way
and
although the growth mindset videos and
and articles are phenomenal for me
personally the best part about
learnstorm is what happens right after
that when the application piece comes in
when we're doing math or coding or
grammar or whatever we're working on and
they go to do their assignments
and there's such
a presence of class synergy because if
you want to see my class suddenly get
silent and excited uh my classmate
manager maddie she'll go up to the board
and they watch her like on pins and
needles because they know she's getting
ready to push
check progress
and they want they want those rings to
fill so badly and they know that every
single one of them contributed to that
happening
um and it you know
i i love though that dave mentioned
dealing with the frustrations um
i had a student who
just she was like just tell me how to do
this one but she just she didn't want to
do it on her own
and
um they know that i won't do that like
i'm here for you talk let's talk through
it tell me don't tell me what you don't
know tell me what you do know and
working through it and that
she left that day totally frustrated and
came back the next day could not wait to
grab her chromebook ran over said she'd
figured it out popped it in and it was
correct
and she was the class hero in that
moment
and i asked her i said how do you feel
right now and she's like oh i feel so
good i did this i said
i would have you wouldn't have felt like
that if i just told you the answer if
they're taking those little moments
to let your kids feel that intrinsic
motivation i think it's really really
powerful in the classroom and learnstorm
kind of gives us that framework at the
beginning to really help establish that
that's what this is like in this
classroom right that's amazing and can i
just ask like as an aside for as a
teacher what is that moment like for you
to experience to see your students kind
of learn and experience that
you know there's a gamut of emotions
when you watch your kiddos learn um
because you feel frustrations along with
them and and you feel the discouragement
too
i have a young man who really has he has
a lot of intense emotions you know that
he's learning to deal with as a lot of
our kids do and he was so frustrated
because we on an assignment that we had
did
he got one out of seven and he was just
so
down and i was like buddy your neurons
found a path you got one
you know and he was like well you know
not very impressed with that response
and i said you know we're gonna do this
again i wanna see if your neurons can
find another path and get two
and he got three and then he said go
away
all right so i went to help other kiddos
and a little bit later he came to me and
he said i need you to close your eyes
and he led me back to his computer and i
realized and he had tears running down
his face and he said seven out of seven
and in that moment like that's why we're
teachers and that's why we do what we do
and that's what we strive for
you know for him to feel that moment and
know he did it on on his own and he gave
his brain the time
to learn and allow his his neurons to
find those pathways
um and it's the other kids see that too
and and it empowers them as much like i
can do this too go away go away i got it
you
so there's a there's a litany of
emotions you feel as a teacher as well
you know you feel the frustrations with
them there's nothing better than the kid
that
they've got it
i love that it definitely seems just
from hearing you all talk in kind of our
earlier conversations that there's
definitely a certain sort of bravery
that has to happen on both the side of
the teacher and the student when
participating in these growth mindset
activities right you have to trust that
your students can do this and that they
can learn and that it's okay to watch
them struggle a little bit and then on
the other end for these students to it's
okay for them to struggle and to work
through things and i think that's a
beautiful lesson i'm not just in class
but just in general
um so this question we have from helen
in utah and i will throw this question
to sam and perhaps everyone with the
demands on the time of day
where do you fit in a growth mindset
activities and what is your favorite
activity
so at the beginning of the year you do
have to make time to do direct lessons
15 25 minutes a day it can involve
a mentor text
such as ish or beautiful oops or you
know the great mistake or any of those
or it can be my kids really like
i actually will show them scans of
brains and we will talk about what's
happening they learn about the neurons
they learn about the parts of the brain
and what they're responsible for and
it's a really powerful moment for them
because a lot of kids come and they
villainize themselves i'm not smart
whereas this gives them okay no this is
what's happening in my brain and i can
grow from this and so we start with that
platform and that does take direct
instruction time at the very beginning
of the school year probably a couple
weeks
and we try to do a lot of activities
along with them
we will read ish and then paint on a
canvas we make calm down jars where the
kids will put glitter and beads in a jar
in their favorite food coloring and talk
about calming our brain you know we talk
about how our body releases stress um
cortisol when we're stressed and we
can't think
and so we do a lot of these activities
at the beginning
we really devote the time to it and i
know we don't have a lot of time as
teachers but the payoff is tenfold from
there it really is about embedding it
into just how you speak to your kids and
how you ask them to speak not only to
you but mostly to themselves
my students have on their desk a picture
of themselves holding a sign they
created that says yet
and at the beginning i got to point to
that picture a lot because they they
they self-doubt and they talk so
negatively to themselves and so i can't
do this and i'll point you and say i
can't do it yet
and then we work really hard to say okay
we consider all day talking about the
things we don't know let's start on this
problem what do you know
you know and it's more it's not about
something you do separate from that
point it's how you empower your students
and how you talk to them and how you
expect them to talk to themselves
and that's really um
the rest of the year it's not something
extra anymore it's just the environment
of your classroom your vocabulary their
vocabulary and i tell them i will never
let anybody be mean to you especially
yourself
and i think a lot of kiddos
they're the meanest to themselves right
i i agree with everything that sam said
i think like in terms of like concrete
activities that you can do definitely
direct instruction for teaching what is
growth mindset and giving them giving
them that vocabulary those tools
understanding how their brains work gut
requires some direct instruction up
front but totally agree that if you do
that little front loading piece and then
you work really hard to embed growth
mindset into your culture it's not
necessarily a kind of activity
but it's um you know for for me i think
like any type of any type of lesson or
activity that requires iterative
thinking or trial and error is going to
allow them to experience a little
struggle experience like trying testing
something it works it doesn't work and
going back to the drawing board
any type of like collaborative
activities are really great for for
working with one another um
project-based learning where there's not
necessarily a right answer
and just coming up with solutions the
the breakouts i think are really great
for getting an or any opportunity for
the kids to have some productive
struggle when you create a challenge
that may be a little just beyond their
capabilities and let them grapple with
that a little bit and those are all good
opportunities but there should just be
things that we're doing every day that
there's always chances and i always
think that the the important pieces that
we debrief afterwards and we talk about
what what was your learning like what
did what did it feel like how did you
push through the difficult parts and i i
think as a learner in my experience as a
learner anyway those most difficult
experiences are the most memorable
experiences they're the ones that i walk
away like i did it you know i
i got through that even if it ended up
being you know a c in algebra to me when
it felt like there was no hope you know
walking out of there and knowing that i
had had got it or had grown that's a
really rewarding experience so so just
embedding it in the culture of your
classroom and and everything you do is
so important right
what um dave anything to add no i think
that's great okay sure i was gonna say
one of one of my favorite things about
what you both said is just the the idea
that we can kind of uh have this
generation of students who don't have to
unlearn these kind of bad kind of
mentalities about themselves and
internalize that and like what kind of
young people can we unleash on the world
if they were just super positive about
what they could accomplish it's so
amazing i love it all right scarlett
from georgia asked what is the best way
to get students excited about growth
mindset i will throw this one to annie
and sam
um so i think
to get to get kids excited is number one
just i think
um sam was saying earlier i'm going to
steal what we were talking about but sam
was saying earlier that kids come to you
already feeling excited about their
potential um or if they come to you
feeling down about their potential if
you could teach them about how their
brains work and how you know with effort
and hard work they can make
accomplishments and make gains in their
learning um that gets them excited
especially when they see progress it
doesn't necessarily have to be um you
know
like a party to get excited about it but
you know i think i think we all are
excited about our own potential and
when you bring that passion into the
classroom and you're developing
relationships with the kids and and
growing those bonds and showing them
that you believe in in their
capabilities teaching them how to
believe in themselves and how to reframe
and refocus um how to be mindful about
how they learn best and apply those
strategies and and give them
opportunities to struggle and come out
on top i think kids get excited about
about learning and about their own their
own possibilities and capabilities yeah
i think so and
you know as adults sometimes
we haven't put ourselves in situations
in a while often that that kids are in
every day
um where we are struggling and we don't
get something and we want to get it um
if you forgot what that feels like i
encourage you to go take a class
do something outside the normal because
there's not a worse feeling in the world
than seeing everybody else get it and
you giving it your all but you don't get
it
and so
growth mindset empowers kids to know
that that's not the period that's not
the end of the story right you know
right exactly
and that doesn't define me this is a
part of my journey and watch me go right
i think modeling and sharing um i
there's lots of teachers have success
with sharing stories of like famous
failures so like
michael jordan was cut from his high
school basketball team or harry potter
was rejected ten times or abraham
lincoln lost his first bid for the you
know illinois house of representatives
or whatever it is like sharing those
stories and letting kids know like like
nobody has like a seamless upward
trajectory in life we all have this kind
of rocky path that we take there's ups
and downs and and the journey towards
success um it requires a lot of that i
think that gets them excited too
hopefully i think fail with your kids
you know a lot of schools now are doing
failure fridays and i love failure
fridays you know the teacher too we're
all learners and we're going to try
something completely out of the norm for
15 minutes we're going to juggle we're
going to try to cook something we're
going to paint we're going to
um try to just do
all sorts of various things that might
be outside the norm and
demonstrate to them that you can't do it
right away either and you know what
congratulations we failed now what right
i love that part like but now what part
that's very very encouraging and
remember that when i fail at
many of the things i try uh yes go ahead
i know that some teachers will actually
make a point to intentionally make
mistakes in front of their students so
that they can really model for them you
know when their students call them out
and say hey that was a mistake they can
model for them the kind of really
adaptive response of that and say oh
yeah you're right that was a mistake
help me help me fix that you know what
did i do wrong and that could really be
this kind of magical time when teachers
can be vulnerable
for their students and really model that
it's okay to make mistakes and the
important thing is to really learn from
learn from each other and learn from
those mistakes right yeah i think that's
very true because you know i think a lot
of teachers feel that they have to kind
of be
kind of perfect and kind of the front of
the classroom and they want to you know
kind of project this image and i think
students learn so much better when they
have someone to relate to and like oh i
see i see someone that i can kind of
grow towards which is really great
i have a question from sarah from bonnie
brae virginia sarah asks how can i best
support a learner with disabilities like
adhd asperger's and so on with concrete
examples scaffolding and growth mindset
that's a really great question i'm going
to throw it up to the whole panel to
answer that question
um
i think any
any kid
can understand like
the basics of how how we learn and what
growth mindset is i mean
as as yeah i've seen you as young as
preschoolers like understand that
concept of what growth mindset is and
how how learning happens in our bodies
and once you start with that foundation
i think it's just really important to
let
let kids know that learning is a journey
and the journey is different for every
person growth mindset is not trying hard
and winning every time like you know
people sometimes have that idea that
that's what it is
being successful and making achieve
and
getting success or achievements look
different for every person for some
people i mean i got a email from a lady
after i wrote a book on growth mindset
and she said well you know i have a
friend and she struggles with the
learning disability
and it took her four times to pass
algebra class and so growth mindset
doesn't work and i said well she passed
it you know it just took four times
and really it's about us changing what
our definition of success looks like
because for for a lot of teachers it's
just getting an a plus a success for a
lot of parents getting an a a six equals
success
but we have to look at it in a different
way sometimes it's starting with a 32
percent and ending up with a 75 getting
one right and then keep working at it
until you get seven right you know it
it's it's a process and i i think no
matter my my own son struggles with
reading and we talk about
what
the way that you learn reading is going
to be different from other people it
might take you a little longer to get it
you might have to employ some different
strategies that other kids don't have to
to do
but you'll get there it's just that this
is your road this is your path and and
you have to embrace that right
dave and dad
okay
annie sorry
um i i think i love everything she said
you know one of my students after a
lesson one day made a comment uh daisy
she said that
even if she's she redefined the way she
was thinking and she goes i'm not going
to think about losing the same way
anymore i said tell me more about that
what do you mean she goes if i lose but
i look at why do i think i lost and what
can i do better next time she goes i'm
going to start counting that half
winning
i thought that was wonderful in my class
we've kind of adopted that and i love
what you said about we we kind of need
to redefine success
it may not look like okay it's 100 on
the spelling test every time it's about
growth for every child where are you and
where do you want to be it's about
putting that goal setting and that
reflection in um and
every child moving forward you know no
matter where they are
that's fantastic great
we have a question from michelle
from juniper california
what is the best way to get parents on
board with the idea of growth mindset
this is such a really important question
because i think a growth mindset can
look very different for many parents who
may not have seen it before or may not
have heard it before
um so how do you get them on board for
this
well i i can start with one thought so i
think exactly i think for a lot of
parents it really is very different than
what they're used to and they might not
understand is this is my kid's teacher
just making up this all this new stuff
that looks totally different than what
i'm used to um they might be very alien
and so i think a good place to start
might be really with just explaining all
the research behind growth mindset i
mean not only that
this is true about our brains but also
uh how what an empowering impact that
has on kids motivation how kids um when
once they once they learn to internalize
the growth mindset how they really end
up being much more likely to challenge
themselves to learn from their mistakes
they to take more challenging classes to
do well in class right so it's um
so the end of the day it's a it's a very
it's really an evidence-based approach
to building students motivation and
ultimately their achievement too so i
think even parents who are really you
know sticklers for the end of the day i
want my kid to learn the most well if
that's what you want then this is
actually how you get there it's by it's
by helping by removing the fear from
learning that might otherwise constrain
them and growth mindset and growth
mindset cultures um can really just do
such a fantastic job of of helping kids
really feel empowered and unleashed to
learn at their best and to really see
themselves growing uh rather than than
being afraid of of of doing poorly um
and uh so i think that's like a great
starting point and then and then i know
these two have some great
suggestions um
we have to look at home as an extension
of the classroom and vice versa and so i
think just giving giving to giving
parents that the tools to understand
what growth mindset is why we do it it's
an evidence-based approach um and then
giving them teaching them strategies to
help them and a lot of times that comes
down to just talking to your kids so you
know there's kind of the old
um cliche like you ask your kid what'd
you do today or what did you do at
school nothing how was it fine
you know you always hear that um but if
parents can be intentional about how
they talk to to their kids after school
i always ask my kids and i we have a
running thing so every day after school
i say best worst and weirdest and so
they have to tell me their best thing
their worst thing and their weirdest
thing which ends up with a lot of funny
stories but it also gives us an
opportunity to kind of dive into okay so
something didn't go very well why not
what was the catalyst for that not going
well or something went great what kind
of strategies did you use to pull that
off i mean how did you prepare how did
you study how did you handle that tricky
um situation on the playground or
whatever
but talking to your kids instead of just
you know good job a on the test ask them
like like how did you prepare for this
what kind of learning went into this and
and um likewise if they didn't do so
well like let's let's talk about what
happened um and so really helping
parents um
build that um communication with their
kids about um
strategies for for learning and and what
works and what doesn't and just and and
having them draw the the
link between effort and achievement is
really important so the kids are hearing
it everywhere they go very good best
worst weirdest i love that super cool
annie i'm sorry sam
and i i think the bottom line
too when it comes to parents is
they are sending us the most precious
gift they have and there is nothing
worse
of a feeling than being a parent and
seeing your child struggle in reading or
struggling math and you want so badly to
fix it for them but you don't know how
and so sometimes when these parents come
to us and they're frustrated and they
just want it fixed they're coming from a
place of love and
we have to train them too you know
because they'll come upset my child is
not a good reader or my child's not
going to mess well now and yet right
right so what are we going to do you
know there really is
if you really want to see the kids just
go far a strong partnership between the
kiddo the teacher and the parent
you know right you've got a big support
system there to really hold up and then
it comes down to what what andy was
talking about earlier all right we've
got our support system holding you now
let's go for some effort right right
exactly
it sounds like a really strong kind of
foundation when you have that that
sounds beautiful
uh we have a question from alyssa b
how would you recommend facilitating and
encouraging other faculty to promote
growth mindset so this is a good
question of like what do you do kind of
in your actual school environment
i think being transparent and being
vulnerable
teachers work really hard and we do not
have a lot of time in the day and
um it's
you know sometimes it's really easy to
hear something and think that's just
another thing
so i think by being transparent and
allowing people to come into your
classroom or see
see the fruits of your kids labor
let your kids lead things you know let
your kids be the ones who go out and
talk about things because that's where
that's where the power lies and that's
where you show that these mountains are
being moved
and then i think also being vulnerable
being able to go to a meeting and say
guys i'm really working on growth
mindset but i really feel like i
personally am failing here i need some
help
and having those open discussions i
think
encourage more people you know we talk
about our students feeling safe but it's
the same thing with the staff the
teachers we've got to feel safe too to
kind of embark on this because it's
uncomfortable at the beginning and it's
a new way of thinking and speaking
and
um there's a big power shift right from
the teacher to the kiddos and that's
nerve-wracking at the beginning right
but it
it it's such a positive power shift
right
scared to take at the beginning right
getting administrators in on it too i
really believe that just like people
approach things with a growth and fixed
mindset that a school has
organizations have a growth or fixed
mindset and a lot of times you don't
have to look further than like the
handbook um to figure out like what are
we valuing here are we valuing growth
are we valuing perfection right and so
getting a good gauge on what is being
valued and how are only the kids who are
getting on the a honor roll are they the
ones that are being celebrated do we
have ways of celebrating kids who are
making um
less um
uh or making incremental steps toward
growth like do we celebrate that at all
in our culture and so as a teacher i
think you have the opportunity to speak
to your admins and say we need to
refocus and and celebrate and like dave
said this is evidence but this is
research based um there's a strong body
of research going back what 30 or 40
years
that that supports this as a valuable
learning intervention and just sharing
that and being
you know being an advocate for it in
your school i think is is key to
changing the culture of the entire
school right
very good yeah the only thing i would
add is just that i mean i think uh the i
when i've talked to teachers who have
kind of uh kind of catalyzed these kinds
of cultural transformations of their
schools i think a lot of the times it's
really happened with uh just a handful
of teachers who really started doing it
and they really started modeling it and
going and talking to other teachers
about it and and and just you know it
took it took some time it wasn't like uh
we're all gonna do growth mindset all at
once i think in my experience that
usually doesn't work very well it's
usually more that you you kind of you
kind of start around this kind of core
crystal group of teachers and then it
kind of branches out from there and as
other teachers can see the kind of
amazing things that can happen right um
and and uh
then they start to say hey maybe maybe
that could work in my class actually i
i'd like to have my kids be that
inspired or that motivated that's
interesting
actually i'm very curious to know uh for
sam what made you want to try out these
growth mindset activities like what was
the catalyst for that
uh it actually stemmed in the beginning
it was
i noticed that my kiddos were coming
without tools and at the time i was in
fifth grade and i had to send you know
my babies off to middle school
and
i wanted them as empowered
and with as many strategies as they
could possibly have before they went
because middle school can be really
difficult years
um
and so i started looking at things like
their perseverance how do they speak to
one another how do they advocate for
themselves when they need something
um
and we started little by little
looking at things like that and i
started really kind of trying to
research and find
um things to support that uh and it's
funny you know we watched beginning
there i show my kids a video of a really
famous
quantum theorist who you know he's
melded science and math and he's been
working on the same equation now for 12
years and i promise my kids i will never
make you work on an equation
but if he can do 12 years we can do 20
minutes right so we started trying to
like build that stamina
and then it it just kind of grew from
there and it was kind of the perfect
timing you know annie's book came out
carol dweck's book um coming out you
know pertz is really on the stage now
learn storms out and it was just it
feels like a lot of us were seeking this
right if you look at the manifestation
of what has really come to the surface
so i think a lot of teachers at the same
time really were feeling the same need
right that's beautiful all right um i'm
glad we can help fill that need that
makes me feel good um leanne morgan from
ontario asks
are there words and phrases that foster
growth that i can include in my student
conversations i think
actually all of you have touched upon
this idea of vocabulary so let's see if
we can uh try to touch on that
i'm a firm advocate of the power of yet
they have any time they say any kind of
negative talk i'll point to them yet
you know and then they have to um say it
and then we're big on our now what
or great um what do you need um we
practice a lot at the beginning of the
year building a toolkit of okay i'm
stuck now so what all right i can ask
for more time i can ask to hear it in a
different way i can ask the teacher to
rephrase it i can ask you know we we
talk about what are the different things
i can do to advocate for myself
because
i i might not always be within these
four walls when i encounter a problem
and i need to have those intrinsic
skills
and so
having that
that vocabulary ready for your kids and
then on the teachers part really trying
to back away from good job that's right
leave it to the class mathematicians
what do you think this mathematician
does propose this idea thoughts
you know um and at the beginning they
just stare at you like
is it right or wrong you know
but they start to learn and it's so
powerful and it is so hard as a teacher
though when somebody throws you know
something wildly incorrect up there but
the cool thing is there's a lot of grace
in that too because when the kids start
debating it and discussing it
we talk about do you have the right to
change your mind and the kid will say oh
i'd like to change my answer and i think
there's so much power in how kids speak
to each other and speak to themselves
and then it's hard for the teacher but
kind of backing up and just
giving those launch points those
launching questions right and then
you're you're crowd control at that
point right very good i think um just
being mindful of like person praise
versus process praise so if we say to a
kid who does really well like oh you're
so smart um they equate doing well with
being smart that it's some some inherent
inborn thing that they have that they
can do well and then when inevitably
they hit a setback which they will um
and they don't do so well then all of a
sudden it's like a question of like well
if i'm not smart then who am i and so
just being mindful of um praising effort
and the process that they took to learn
like that was a really great strategy
you use or i like how you solve that
problem or if they breeze through
something maybe that wasn't challenging
enough let's try to find something else
so being mindful of that um
being more robust with your feedback i
think we like to use stickers and say
good job a lot in the in the book i
wrote we call it
well i read it somewhere else but they
call it paula pray so like on american
idol
if you think back to american idol like
the first
with simon and paula and randy
paula would always say good job
and and simon was a lot meaner but he
was much more specific and so you don't
want to be be like that but definitely
be specific and the the feedback that
you're giving um
and i would rather have less feedback
that's more specific than generalized
that that is really meaningless so so
you want to be be mindful of that and
then um
yeah i just think thinking about that i
used to say
um come on you can do this it's so easy
and that was something i said as a
teacher and i look back and think oh my
gosh you know what that wasn't easy for
that person it was easy for me or i
thought it was easy but it wasn't easy
for that person and so what i was saying
was actually not helping it was
counterproductive and i thought i was
being helpful and so just like really
being mindful of what you're saying and
how that that affects the student that
you're working with is really important
yeah i really love all those points um
yeah i guess just uh from a growth
mindset standpoint i i think the
the kinds of of language we use is the
kinds of words we use can be really
important and and there are
so for example are you referring to
things as for example we can talk about
building skills like really calling out
when you're doing something like why are
you doing it oh you're you're building
your skills you're becoming a
mathematician or you're building you're
building your writing skills right now
or you're becoming a better writer or um
we're really really focusing students on
those processes and kind of how the fact
that they're learning while while
they're doing so it's kind of taking
again you know taking the focus off of
the end result and really focusing it on
the thing that the students can actually
control for themselves which is the
process that they're doing and really
reminding them and kind of debriefing
with them so that they really understand
what it is that they're doing and that
all this effort they're doing it's not
just going into a grade it's going to
them leveling up them becoming a writer
then becoming a mathematician or a
scientist or whatever that may be a
great civic thinker
whatever that may be they're really
developing those skills and really
making sure to call out that that
learning is a process that they're
enacting in your class right so not just
like work for the sake of work but work
for the sake of of of growth of growth
and betterment i love that all right so
we're going to wrap up
um i'm going to actually throw you a bit
of a curve ball and ask you a final
question but with a challenge um so what
is one last piece of advice for teachers
for fostering growth mindset that you
would give this year if you can give it
in 10 words or less
oh i know
all right i'm going to start with dave
have a growth mindset about building a
growth mindset culture
was that too high i think i did that
right okay
all right go ahead annie
one last piece of advice for teachers i
would say um model
your growth and fixed mindsets and
normalize mistakes
in your classroom
well done well done i like it all right
sam your last name um okay
be vulnerable
be a champion for your kids and model
i love that that was very good and all
very tweetable very great
uh so i want to thank dave and annie and
sam for joining us today i learned
something and i hope that you all did
too
i want to remind everyone that there's
still some time to sign up so if you
haven't signed up please sign up like
right now today
but definitely by the end of october um
and if you uh keep on tagging your
classroom celebrations with hashtag
learnstorm on twitter and facebook we
really love seeing in the office um so
please keep on doing that um welcome
back to the school year's teachers thank
you and goodbye
you